good morning guys and welcome back to
the channel it is currently a Saturday
morning as I struggle to get this video
out in time uh due to being out of town
the last weekend uh but at the same time
I'm still procrastinating hitting legs
so hopefully this one will take a decent
amount of time so I don't have to go
ahead and squat because I hate that
anyways today we're going to be talking
about Dropbox and Google Drive so we can
go ahead and get into that and do video
number three okay so as I mentioned
today we're going to be talking about
Dropbox or Google Drive the one thing I
should note is that as I actually think
about the design that I went for for
this video it turned out to actually be
pretty simple to what we did in our last
kind of social media Twitter you know
news feed post video so if you haven't
seen that one I would recommend watching
that first I wouldn't say I'm brushing
through things but there are things that
I went a little bit more in depth into
last episode and as a result of that I
think it is going to benefit you to
actually be watching those in order
anyways let's talk about what Dropbox
and Google Drive actually are so for
those of you who are uncultured we've
got this idea of like some sort of cloud
file system which is just a black box
and if we've got me over here writing a
file to it uh that file might be shared
with you know uh three different users
one two and three and then as you can
see you know they might be on their
phone over here that change is going to
be instantly propagated to them so this
would be user one user
two user three and of course you know
assuming they have right permissions
they can do the same thing right back
into this and then that should be
propagated back over to me barring any
sort of right conflicts or anything like
that and we'll talk about that in a bit
so let's actually go ahead and formalize
the requirements of this problem so for
one like I mentioned if you're a user
you can create and upload a file to our
Dropbox or our Google Drive another
thing is that multiple different users
can see those files as we showed in the
above diagram another thing is that
changes to files should be propagated to
all the devices with access I shouldn't
have to like load up a you know load up
a client and then and be like hey can
you give me the most updated file I
should be able to actually just see it
uh assuming that client has been
passively open in the background so
should be propagated and then of course
uh this is a small requirement but uh
just nice for history sake we should be
able to see versions of files so after a
file is edited uh we should be able to
recreate the older version of the file
um assuming that there is an older
version and so again uh for a problem
like this you can see that it's not
necessarily the reads or the rights that
are going to be bottlenecking us there's
probably not that much of either of them
it can just get a little bit complex to
do all of this versioning uh the sharing
with the users and so I think we're
going to be less bottlenecked by speed
and more bottlenecked by actually you
know keeping uh the program to be not
too intensive on our client devices so
we can think about how we'll do that in
a little bit okay so let's come up with
some quick capacity estimates so as per
usual I'm pretty much just making these
up they're very handwavy so uh you know
don't come after after me too hard but
I'm assuming around a billion users
around 100 docks per user which I think
is pretty reasonable obviously there are
going to be some users who have in the
thousands or even more than that but I
think 100 is pretty reasonable for the
most part assuming each document is
around 100 kilobytes so that's saying
around 100,000 characters per document I
also think that's reasonable some might
be in megabytes not really a huge deal
uh then if we're going to go ahead and
see how much storage that accounts for
in terms of actual documents themselves
we've got a billion users 100 documents
for user 100 kilobytes overall and that
comes out to 100 terabytes of docs which
is really not too much I'm sure that in
reality companies like Google Drive and
uh Dropbox are storing quite a bit more
than that I mean I personally have
almost like 12 gigabytes of storage in
my Google Drive so you know it's clear
that there are going to be certain power
users taking up quite a bit more than
that but assuming we use something like
an object store like S3 effectively
that's infinitely scalable uh storage is
not going to be our constraint here okay
so another thing is that most documents
are shared with less than 10 people and
some might be shared with many thousands
and this is going to come uh in handy or
rather it's going to be important when
we discuss how we can actually propagate
the changes for a given document over to
all of the interested users so I wrote
that over there okay moving on from
capacity estimates let's start talking
about document permissions so as I
mentioned a given document can be shared
with multiple different users and when I
say document I I use that term
interchangeably with file uh that being
said though can store any type of
arbitrary file it doesn't just have to
be a document so I'm sorry if that uh
gets confusing at times that's honestly
an error on my part but uh hopefully it
still makes sense so the schema for
something like this as I go over here
would be we've got a user ID on one side
a document ID on the other side so if a
user ID and a document ID appear
together that means the user has access
to that document now to keep this quick
to keep basically the queries quick on
this table I feel that it is a good idea
to index based on the user ID and also
Shard our partitions based on the user
ID the reason being that we are
occasionally going to have to query and
figure out for a given user which
documents do they have access to this
might happen if you know you didn't have
a client open then you start it up after
a long while we need to figure out
quickly which documents I might have
access to so that I can actually pull
them from the server it's not always
going to be the case that we get to push
the documents to the user if their
client's not literally open then you
know there's just nothing you can do
about that so to uh you know give some
perspective on what that might look like
you know that would literally just be
like you know if I'm user one and user
one lives on Shard one then I would
first query that and then I would go and
query this black box of a file service
to get all of our files so hopefully
that makes a little bit of sense uh
behind the indexing and the sharding
choices uh but this table schema should
be simple enough so then a quick uh
tangent before we go onwards is you know
what actual type of permissions database
should we be using now uh you know in
order to decide a database typically I
like to think about what type of
replication is feasible for us and of
course if we do need a type of
replication that's going to enable
better performance whether you know we
have performance constraints here to
actually justify that so I was thinking
in this case that single uh single
leader replication may actually be best
so the reason for my thinking there is
that imagine that uh we were to give a
user permission for a certain document
and then we were to quickly remove
permission for that user so if we have
like a liter one on the left over here
and a liter two on the right keep in
mind that adding a user and giving them
permission then removing it is a causal
dependency it doesn't make sense to
remove a user's permission unless
they've already been added and it
wouldn't be great as well if for some
reason um you know that remove didn't go
through right so when these guys
eventually sync up with one
another you can see that the database
based on last right win is just going to
be like hm did they add or did they
remove and then it's going to be unclear
one of these might arbitrarily win now
you might be thinking to yourself well
we can actually make this work with
something like a crdt so for those of
you who are less familiar there crdts
would basically be a special data
structure that goes on each of these
leader nodes and the idea would be to
use something like a set crdt so that
when we add permission for a given user
and then we've remove it on another
leader basically the gist of the crdt is
that they will eventually converge to a
value that makes sense so for a set crdt
what we would actually do is you know we
would um we would basically say here's a
tombstone for you know the
permission and here is the add of the
permission and then when we merge those
via anti-entropy we can see that the ad
and the tombstone are both present
presumably there can only be a tombstone
if there was first an ad at some point
and then that would go ahead and
converge to the fact that the user no
longer has permissions frankly though I
think this is all a bit over kill the
reason being that we probably don't
update user permissions that much and as
a result I would rather just do single
leader replication that way we don't
have to worry about causality we know
that all rights are already going to be
reflected on the single leader and so
for a table like this I would basically
just use my SQL I think that if we
really needed to scale out our right
through put a little bit more what we
could do is just go ahead and partition
it a little bit more and the number of
partitions is going to increase our
right throughput okay so we've gone on
that nice little tangent now let's
actually start to talk about file
uploading so one thing that would be
majorly useful for us here is if we take
a given
file we go ahead and split it into a
bunch of smaller chunks now why would we
do that well there are actually a couple
reasons for starters when we upload
files to
S3 or object storage or wherever we're
eventually going to be putting them we
can do this in parallel uh you know we
have multiple threads on our client
device one of them can you know manage
each chunk and the upload of it that
should make things a little bit faster
another thing is that we can only load
the modified chunks on every single
change so let's say um our client device
already has access to these three chunks
right here and then this guy is
new we can just go ahead and pull this
guy right so we have a lot less to pull
from S3 we just pull one quarter of the
chunks the con is of course that as a
result of switching a bunch of files
over to effectively a bunch of mini
files for starters now our client has to
perform a bunch of extra logic to figure
out you know what chunks actually
changed on a given file edit and
additionally we now have to keep track
of all those chunks in our application
itself we need to keep track of them in
the database so let's talk about how we
can actually do that what we're
effectively going to do is create a
chunks database and so what I have over
here is an example of file and as you
can see we've got four different chunks
for it now the chunks themselves are of
course Min files but within them I'm
also going to take the hash of each so
the so that we can represent them nicely
within a database so what would that
look like well we've got our chunks
table here with the following schema we
have an ID a version because keep in
mind we have to keep versions of all of
our files so that we can reconstruct
older versions of them the hash of the
chunk and then the link within S3 or
maybe our object storage so keep in mind
that every single chunk for a given
version is going to have its
corresponding entry in this table but at
the same time there are probably going
to be a lot of duplicate chunks from
version to version and what that means
is that we're going to be able to store
less data in S3 we can use chunks uh
multiple times even if it's for
different versions which is good now
notice I said over here you could also
use a wide column or a document format
there's no reason that all of these
things have to be a separate row we
could just have one
row um per ID plus version and then you
know uh the hashes would be like a list
or something or a map from hash to link
anything like that would work but but uh
the reason that I've basically created a
schema like this is that if we index by
R ID and then do an inner sort on
version it means that queries to the
chunks table quickly allow us to figure
out basically all of the the chunk
hashes that comprise a version because
this is all going to go to one single
partition we don't need to do any sort
of aggregation on an aggregator node and
additionally the index within every
single partition is going to make those
queries fast so I think it's a pretty
reasonable schema here so let's actually
start to think about uh what database we
want to use for our chunks database cuz
I would think that as opposed to the
permissions table it's possible that at
least for some documents the performance
of our chunks database might be a little
bit of a constraint well within a single
leader we basically need to be able to
make sure that there is only one version
of a given file right I can't have two
users writing version four of the same
file at the same time so we would need
to do some sort of locking where
basically if this guy says I'm grabbing
version 4
and another guy does the same exact
thing and we can do this either via
predicate locks or just grabbing a lock
on the file ID itself uh we need the
database to only say okay for one of
these guys and then for the other guy
basically go tell them to kick rocks and
try again and then this guy could you
know pull the file from the database
merge it in locally and then go ahead
and make a new version of it that would
be a lot more ideal that being said this
works when there is a single leader in
the multi-leader case it gets a little
bit more complicated so imagine that uh
you know we've got leader one on our
left leader 2 on our right they both try
to lock and grab version four of a
specific file but then on
anti-entropy what's going to happen is
that these two are going to sync up with
one another both leaders and then it's
basically going to be arbitrary which
version 4 is actually going to win
because you know tables like these
typically tend to use last right wins so
one of them is going to get clobbered
based on some arbitrary BS distributed
timestamp which doesn't really
accurately reflect you know Literal time
and as a result of that now all of a
sudden that whole file history that we
wanted to preserve is not properly
preserved because one of these guys just
gets completely lost from our database
and that is the worst possible scenario
so if we did really need the extra right
through putut of using a leaderless
replication database we could actually
still do this so I'm going to show how
we might do that in a second by making
use of something called siblings now
I've spoken about siblings a little bit
in my systems Design Concepts videos but
the idea basically is that you have two
rights to different leaders of the
database right so same partition but it
could be two different leaders and if we
are able to detect the fact that they
are concurrent what we can do is
actually store both of those rights at
the same time and then a future user
who's going to load that file will be
able to load them locally merge them and
then upload just one singular version
for you know the next iteration so I'll
explain that a little bit more
concretely so right now imagine that uh
this database for this file on the left
here has a version Vector 2 comma 1 what
that basically means is that two rights
have come from leader
one to you know establish a new version
and one right has come from leader two
now as you can see clearly for this
particular key or for this particular
ular file we're nicely in sync with
leader 2 which also agrees that there
have been two rights to lader
one and one right to leader
two so right now we're starting out as
if everything is in sync so the next
thing would be imagine that we've got
two guys two users writing to both
leaders at the same time so if this guy
is going to write to leader one the
version Vector that he would procure
would basically be 3 comma 1 because now
there's going to be an extra right to
leader one the guy on the right is going
to be writing to leer 2 so he would have
a version Vector of sorry typo here it
would be not 2 comma 1 but 2 comma 2
because he's adding one extra right to
leader number two and So eventually when
these guys do anti-entropy which
basically means that the multiple
leaders are going to try and sync up
with one another well what we would
notice is that version vectors for 3
comma 1 and 2 comma 2 indicate that the
rights did not know about one another
meaning they were concurrent the reason
they didn't know about one another is
because when you look at these version
vectors you can see that at every single
index of the corresponding version
vectors one is greater than the other
and uh one is less than the other and
that kind of is going to indicate
concurrency because concurrency like I
mentioned means that the two rights were
not fully aware of one another uh before
they actually happened and so again if
the version vectors are in this state it
means that they were concurrent so what
we can do is we see hey these two
version vectors for these particular
rights were concurrent as opposed to
just storing the files as V4 we can
actually store them as v4.1 meaning this
guy came from leader 1 and v4.2 meaning
this guy came from leader 2 and so again
next time that a user goes and loads
that file they're going to have to merge
it locally now I think this does add a
little bit of extra complication to uh
our system that frankly we don't
necessarily need again I would prefer to
just use a MySQL based approach so that
we can avoid storing siblings where
we're doing locking we're telling users
that submit a bad request to basically
go back load the file again and then
upload it um but I can see the case
being made for siblings as well if you
just want users to be able to get their
file up the first time that they try so
again let's try and avoid storing
siblings uh if we really needed the
extra right through put such that
multi-leader replication was necessary
uh then maybe we would have to do
something like this so again right
throughput as required now the last
option in theory would to be to use some
sort of file crdt right where if it's
possible that rather than ever having a
client have to merge two files we could
somehow do it during the anti-entropy
process like use some special data
structure here and here that somehow
knows how to merge two different
concurrent changes to files but the
issue with that is this isn't like
Google Docs where we're exclusively
working with documents we could be
working with documents photos uh audio
anything like that and there's not
really like a generalized crdt to be
able to merge any single type of file so
this approach probably isn't going to
work we're just going to have to ask our
clients to merge them somehow whenever
there's a conflict so keep in mind that
basically what I've said about these
chunks DB so far is that we definitely
want atomicity right because we're
uploading multiple rows at a time uh in
our schema over here you know if I'm
uploading four rows at a time I want
them to all go through or I want them to
all fail and we definitely need
serializability because we want to make
sure that if I'm writing to our single
leader and then someone else is also
writing to the single leader that it's
important that the database is going to
explicitly choose one of us to grab that
next version so we need serializability
we need acidity it would be nice to just
have transactions and so ultimately I
think that my SQL is again the best
choice here I do mention that
partitioning is going to allow us to
increase our right through put and we
can partition basically to our hearts
content as long as we ensure that all of
the same file IDs are on the same node
we can just Partition by hash
range of file ID and if even that really
got bad we could do file ID and version
for partitioning but I think file ID
should probably be
sufficient okay so let's go ahead and
talk about uploading the actual file now
that we've spoken about uploading the
file metadata so again the idea here is
that the reason we break these files
into chunks is so that not only do we
get the parallelism here but we can only
upload the new chunks to S3 and that's
going to save us both time and storage
so the question is if we have to upload
to both S3 over here and then also to
the database how should we do it well we
could use something like a two-phase
commit right and ensure that everything
that goes to S3 is also going to make
its way to the database in terms of the
metadata however the issue with that is
it's going to seriously slow down our
latency by quite a bit um and ideally we
want to be able to make this process
relatively seamless from the client side
so what I've opted to do instead is
let's imagine that these two chunks down
here are new well we should have two
parallel rights at the same time first
to S3 and when we get news that those
have completed then we can upload our
meta to the uh metadata to the chunks
database so as you can see that's going
to be a lot better on the client side
but it does come at the risk of certain
files basically ending up in S3 and you
know if this right fails to the chunks
DB for a variety of reasons maybe it was
a uh right that causes a merge conflict
or something like that then now we're
just going to have some ghost chunks in
S3 so what could we actually do well we
could have a cleanup job which
occasionally pulls S3 and then checks if
the chunk is somewhere in the chunks
database to see if we actually need it
for any of our file versions now you
might be thinking well you know how how
can we quickly query the database once
we know an S3 file name perhaps we could
give every single S3 chunk name like uh
you know formatted like file
ID
version uh chunk
has uh. s3.com or something like that if
we were able to do that that would make
life pretty easy and then we would be in
good
shape okay so let's go ahead and talk
about file changes to users um so to
make this clear we every single time uh
a user is going to change a file we
would like to be able to show all the
other users user one user two user three
we'd like to be able to show them uh
that change as quickly as possible
assuming that their client is actively
open and connecting to our servers so
this is where we start actually getting
into a very similar design that we had
for the news feed again ideally we don't
want to be uh like polling for changes
from our devices because the idea is to
have them there instantly as they happen
and additionally it's very important to
us that for a given client device we
keep the number of connections
maintained to a minimum now ideally we
would keep that number of connections
maintained to one this is just going to
use less battery on the client device
use less data generally it's a good
thing and so the way we would do that is
by having some sort of cache similar to
Twitter or Q or anything like that that
is representative of each user however
there's going to be an issue here which
is that a certain amount of our files
are going to be very popular right so
let's imagine this guy has you know
10,000
users that would involve publishing to
10,000 different places and that is
probably infeasible we saw the same
exact issue uh when we were doing the
Twitter systems design and so as a
result similarly to Twitter what we can
actually end up doing is opting for a
hybrid approach so the majority of the
uh the documents or the files in our
system are going to have very few users
that care about them and as a result
when we see the changes to that file we
can push it to all of the given users
that we need to that's going to keep
things nice and easy however for super
popular documents or super popular files
many different users are going to have
access so it would be better instead if
we could just push those uh files to one
place and then all of the users could
connect to that so yeah maybe a user
isn't going to have 100 open connections
one for each document but they might
have say 10 open connections where we've
got one for all of their documents that
are unpopular and you know maybe another
nine for all of the popular documents
ideally we would only have to have a few
different places that you would connect
to for the popular documents because
there are far fewer of them so again the
idea here is that it's a little bit
worse than having one connection but it
is far more pragmatic because otherwise
we would run into this problem right
here where we would publish popular
files to a million different places
so let's actually talk about file
routing because we can draw out this
approach and ensure that everything is
going to the right place based on how
many users have permissions to access it
so when a file gets changed we need to
go ahead and propagate the changes to
the right place and this is going to
look very very similar to the news feed
design so if you saw that again same
kind of concept so we've got our file
right here we're going to make an edit
first place it goes to is the chunks DB
of course S3 as well but that's not too
relevant for this part of the DI diagram
and so once we go ahead and make that
change into our chunks database what we
can do is use something like change uh
change data C capture can't speak this
morning too early and so once we
actually have all of those changes in
Kafka flowing through we can keep
everything sharted by file ID because at
the end of the day this is all a per
file process we don't really have to
have data for more than one file at the
same place and this can go into an
instance of Apache Flink which can also
be sharded by file ID
the reason we want to do this is so that
for every single given file we can
actually quickly figure out which users
have permissions for it so the only way
that we're able to do that is by also
having the permissions DB use change
data capture which again flows into
Flink now the interesting thing that you
might remember is that we did say our
permissions database would be sharded by
user ID whereas in this case we want
everything sharded by file ID so our
Kafka q that is carrying the change data
capture needs to also be sharded by file
ID so that basically when the
permissions database gets changed it'll
flow those changes properly through and
then of course we can organize things
such that we have good data locality the
reason we want to be using Flink here is
that if we weren't using Flink and this
was just some you know normal bum
consumer it would have to make calls to
the database every single time to figure
out which users have permission for a
given file and that would be very slow
and in addition our our schema isn't
even good for that particular use case
so we would have to derive like a second
database that is sharded by file ID
instead so that would be annoying too I
think this is a better approach and then
of course once we see a given file we
can say well does it have over 100,000
users that follow it if so send it to
one of the popular files caches or cues
or whatever we're going to eventually
choose for that which is going to be
sharded by file
ID and then if it's not if say there are
only three users who are you know kind
of caring about those changes we can
send it to the unpopular files area and
that would be sharded by user ID so if
there were three users we would probably
send that to three different places
depending on how our sharding works
here so hopefully that makes sense and
looks very similar to Twitter as you can
see uh learning One Design is already
coming in handy for getting better at
the
others cool so let's talk about the
actual metadata reading because this is
how a user is going to read a file once
they see that the metadata has has
changed so basically the question is
well what device should we actually use
as the sync right we say popular files
and I have kind of just like a general
rectangle over here but what actual
technology should this thing
be ultimately I wanted to use Kafka uh
the reason being that users are
basically just long polling from it
which may not be the best technological
choice for our use case but at the end
of the day I think it should be uh be
fine uh Kafka is kind of built to be
consumed from multiple times which I
think helps when you have multiple
different users per aova q and
additionally if a user were to go down
for a few seconds then come back up
rather than making a full big query to
the database they could just read from
where they already were in the cofa Q so
again this is going to ensure that
clients that go down can reread their
Mis changes but anyway the general
process should look something like this
if this is our Kafka Q over here and
it's telling us for a given file uh what
chunks have changed you can see now that
it's going to say for example file to
the new version has chunk c d and e now
the client might say to itself oh wait a
second I already have a b and c locally
so you would see that there's overlap in
file chunk number C or letter C and so
then we can take the diff of those two
sets and say I'm going to S3 now please
get me chunks d and e and once they do
you can recreate that file locally so
that should be a relatively easy process
which is good again the fact that we're
using chunks is going to allow us to
actually load less of them from s three
because we just take what already uh
what we already have locally and then
get the
difference okay finally we have made it
to the end so let's go ahead and get
through this as you can see we've got
the full on design so the idea over here
is that we're going to start with a file
writer on the
left and then a file
reader on the right so what can the file
writer do well basically the first thing
that they can do do is add permissions
for a given user so that would go to our
horizontally scaled permission service
and as we've already discussed a
permissions database which we can Shard
on user ID and also index on user ID so
the query to figure out all of the
documents that a given user has access
to is nice and quick additionally they
can also upload a file and when they do
we mentioned that the first thing that
would happen is it would go over to S3
and then the second thing that would
happen is we would go over to the chunk
service now note that for our S3 we
should most certainly be using cdns to
keep particular file loads fast for a
lot of users uh specifically our popular
files we definitely want to be loading
those in the CDN we could either
pre-populate that from flank which is
one option over here or just do some
sort of um you know poll based approach
where as users are accessing chunks of
files uh and those get particularly
popular uh the cdns will just hold on to
them and that would be good for popular
files as well we would use like an lru
replacement or something like like that
so again the idea here is that first we
put the actual chunk
data then we've got our chunk
metadata going to our chunk service
which again is going to flow into our
chunks mySQL database we want to
partition this on file ID so that
loading all of the chunks for a
particular file and version is
particularly fast and then index upon
file ID and version within that so that
for a given version we can quickly
figure out what chunks that is going to
contain
so from both of these tables we're now
using change data capture oops
accidental erase from both of these
tables we are using change data capture
to get data into Kafka which is again
going to be partitioned on file ID and
then we are going to get it into flank
again partitioned on file ID so if you
recall what that's basically saying is
hey file number one has user two and
user 3 and the reason we need to know
for a given file which users have
permission to it is so that we can even
either send that change up here over to
the popular file changes cues so that's
option one if say it has more than
10,000 followers or 10,000 users
assigned to it or option two would be
you know say it's only got a couple of
users that need to know about these
changes send it to the specific
partitions of cues that we care about
for those users so for example if uh
user two and user three were on
different kofka qes Maybe this would be
a time two and we would have to send it
to a couple of different places the last
aspect of this is we've got our file
reader right here so let's say this is
user
2 user 2 knows what documents it cares
about or what files it cares about so it
can go connect to the queue for user 2
automatically and then it can connect to
all of the cues for our popular files
and kind of just filter out those
changes as needed now if there are too
many of these popular file changes cues
then we may have to do an optimization
to basically support some sort of data
structure which tells us which popular
files a given user cares about and then
as a result of that only connect to the
proper cues that we need that's not too
hard too it would take a little bit of
extra derived data and a little bit of
uh logic with our zookeeper But
ultimately I think for now we can keep
things simple and just have the user
connect to every single popular file cue
I imagine there would probably only be
like 10 at most so hopefully this makes
sense to you guys I hope it was somewhat
useful and uh yeah in the next couple of
weeks we're going to crank out a few
more of these so as always if you have
any questions or constructive criticism
none of my designs are perfect I'm kind
of making these up on the Fly because
you know I feel that if I look at
everyone else's YouTube videos all of my
designs are going to be the same as them
and I wouldn't really have any novelty
to what it is that I'm making I even
watched my old Google Drive video uh
before making this one and uh I can say
for a fact that you know I I saw a few
of the choices that I made there and I
didn't like them and so that's why I
deviated from that Old design a little
bit to use more of a hybrid approach
rather than just having these user cues
over here so guys have a great weekend
and I will see you soon